[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
maurizio serra de l'académie française
pour son livre le mystère mussolini qui
a reçu le grand prix de la biographie
politique
on va passer toute cette émission sur
celui que vous présentez comme le plus
sibyllin de tous les dictateurs du 20e
siècle le moins facile à cerner mais
commençons par une image et plutôt trois
images celles que vous avez choisi pour
symboliser notre époque voici la
première
qui existe en plusieurs langues qu'est
ce que vous avez dit et bien
évidemment il ya une différence
considérable entre les deux sujets
pourtant populisme peuple peuple c'est
la base de la démocratie et donc il
pourrait y avoir quelque chose qui les
rassemble plus de coller que les diviser
mais il faudrait passer par la raison la
responsabilité et le réalisme les 3r qui
manque souvent aux populistes la
deuxième image
s'est elle est bien l opportunité
immense que les nouvelles technologies
l'audiovisuel donne à l'enseignement des
enfants mais connaîtront-ils la réalité
resteront ils dans le virtuel et surtout
lire ont-ils des livres oui suggestion
composaient déjà ma génération qui
aiment regarder la conclusion et c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs - regarde moins de
gens lisaient que nous il n'y en avait
qui regardaient la télévision troisième
image plus énigmatique et bien c'est
l'image qui était prise je crois sur une
représentation d'un opéra de luigi nono
mais finalement c'est la beauté qui est
prisonnière qui a engagé et c'est un peu
le signe de notre temps je crois que
nous avons besoin de plus de beauté et
de moins de cages
et bien commençons
[Musique]
non ici au cera vous êtes le premier
italien à avoir été élu à l'académie
française c'était en 2020 vous êtes
diplomate historien écrivain vaudois des
biographies de marinetti de mal à partes
d'italo svevo de d'annunzio est
maintenant de mussolini aux éditions
perrin vous l'avez intitulé le mystère
mussolini pourquoi il y aurait un
mystère mussolini alors qu'il n'y aurait
pas de mystère hitler ou une mystère
staline dont trois raisons
essentiellement la première c'est que
l'homme étant finalement comedia
comédiens meech et a donc un comédien
tragique a tellement de retomber dans sa
vie qu'il aurait pu avoir prendre des
chemins très différents
alors que si vous prenez un hitler
staline est un cas particulier
vous voyez que du début à la fin c'est
un jusqu'au boutiste dans une seule
direction l'idéologie même chez vous
soulignez extrêmement mouvante première
raison deuxième raison du mystère et du
côté sibyllin du dictateur c'est que
contrairement à l'image et aux poncifs
qu'on en a d'un personnage très évident
évident entre m ubuesque parfois un peu
grotesque c'est un homme extrêmement
rentrée c'est un homme qui n'a jamais
d'interlocuteurs il n'est jamais même
entourée d'une petite bande comme hitler
ou staline le sort dans le caddie clair
c'était d'ailleurs dangereux d'opsens
dans ce petit banques parce que vous
risquez de ne pas survivre donc tout est
replié en lui mais il m'a aidé à me
dites vous des regrets c'est lui qui l'a
dit dit locaux oui le dis parce
qu'évidemment disons la côte et même
romantique de la solitude du pouvoir
mais c'est une réalité est évidemment
c'est un le cas
houde dans lequel il fini et c'est le
troisième fois par oublier le réalisme
qui a été sa grande ressource de
politiciens au début et au fur et à
mesure il s'enlise dans une sorte de
château des mystères dans un dans un
village potemkine il ne voit plus la
réalité ni de son pays ni de l'europe
réalisme dites vous mais pourtant
vous dites qu'il mentait tout le temps
et notamment pour conquérir le pouvoir
de mensonges qu'il va utiliser à
l'époque l'idée d'une d'une italie trahi
par ses alliés après la première guerre
mondiale qui on aurait volé son son
butin de guerre donc sa victoire et puis
sur le risque d'une révolution
bolchévique en italie qui d'après ce que
vous dites mais j'aime existe et non
d'un les deux sont certainement des
mensonges ou en tout cas des
dissimulations parce que l'on parle de
mensonge nous parlons toujours d'une
dimension politique sur laquelle les
prépare une plateforme
d'ascencio pouvoir la première c'est un
fait les nationalistes et mélasse même
dan nout exploite l'idée de la victoire
mutilé par la mauvaise volonté des
alliés ce n'est pas vraiment le cas
disons que grosso modo 80% des buts de
guerre débute pour lesquels l'italie
était en train au regard du côté des
ailiers sont obtenus à la fable à la fin
du conflit
d'autre part l'autre la fragilisation
par des remous ball chez visant c'est
quelque chose qui a lieu au moment
surtout de l'occupation des usines du
nord en 1919 20 mai largement résolue
avant l'ascension de mussolini et avant
la marche se robe donc il n'y avait pas
de risque
pour nous et rangez vous l'avez rappelé
il ya un côté très théâtral le bouffon
chez michou mussolini que chaplin
d'ailleurs a magnifié dans le dictateur
on se souvient de la prestation de jack
o qui on va retrouver son visage et
mussolini c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit le
torse bon b le menton relevé à la fois
martial il vous lantin vulnérables on se
dit qu une espèce de césar de carnaval
on se demande comment ça a pu marcher
auprès des italiens oui justement c'est
une question que je me pose souvent je
pense qu'elle parle quand même d'un
certain même si vous voulez d'un certain
poncifs parce que au fond nous avons un
homme qui reste pouvoir pendant 20 ans
toutes les images comme pas sont des
images des années 30 et surtout de la
deuxième moitié des années 30 ou même le
port constant de l'uniforme uniforme
sans grade d'ailleurs est la conséquence
de la militarisation du pays qui doit se
préparer à la guerre mais à les voir
toutes les photos de mousseline et des
années 20 jusqu'à la boîte et des années
30 et vous voyez un homme d'état qui est
certainement non démocrates cela va sans
dire mais qui est quand même
l'interlocuteur des personnages de son
temps et de son époque donc il faut
quand même remettre ça dans la
perspective de la longue durée du régime
ce qui évidemment est particulièrement
difficile en france j'aime bien je bois
de problèmes quand j'en parle avec des
amis espagnols vu la longue durée du
fascisme du franquisme ou des eaux des
amis même russe vu la longue durée du
biochimiste mais le fascisme france
n'est de deux facteurs la défaite et
l'occupation qui n'ont rien à voir et en
plus se concentre une période
heureusement très rigoureuses ce qui n'a
rien à voir avec loewen teignant du
bushisme italien et c'est vrai que là on
le voit il est en 1926 il était ce qu'il
était le même il est il est en civil et
en civil
mais vous n'avez pas répondu
qu'est-ce com - est-ce que les italiens
qu'être subjugué par le par mussolini
écoutez je crois qu'il y à trois
facteurs qui jouent évidemment c'est une
question qui n'a pas encore de réponse
et vous trouverez
les réactions les plus variés chez les
chercheurs
et chez les auteurs en italie un partout
par celle qui est hélas pourrait-on dire
la moins importante des trois c'est la
répression parce qu'il ya certainement
une répression forte le contrôle de la
police le contrôle
d'un même de l'emploi qui est également
quelque chose de très important la
corruption qui joue
tout cela mais finalement il y a surtout
au début une conviction assez large je
ne dirais pas majoritaire parce que nous
n'avons pas mes instruments qui puisse
nous le dire nous ne faut pas la
possibilité de sondages ou autre que
quand même l'homme fait n'oubliez pas
l'union des trois forces essentielles de
la société italienne de son époque la
monarchie l'église et l'état oui
effectivement
il conduit lui-même son alfa romeo et
autres bolides y pilote son avion il se
donne
en tout cas au début mais même même à
cette époque là l'image de l'homme
nouveau l'homme futuriste d'ailleurs on
a souvent lié le fascisme des premiers
temps avec le futurisme italien il se
met vous dit qu'il n'est pas si moderne
que cela au fond pas parce qu'il ya une
contradiction l'homme est pétri de
contradictions
le mais pétrie d'ailleurs même sous
l'image son image d' esbroufe d'image de
deux grandes de comment dirais-je
d'assurance physique et
l expression de quelqu'un qui est
intimement fissures et lacérés de doute
et de contradictions et alors dans le
cas spécifique où il est moderne c qui
comprend qu'il faut bien qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une autre image une image
misons un terme jeunes de la politique
et donc qu'ils soient sportives qu'ils
soient linverse de ce que les croulants
hommes politiques de la vieille europe
ont produit lors de la pré peur de la
veille et pendant la grande guerre ça
doit être le premier qui s'exhibe torse
nu déjà quand tu as tout à côté de cela
il y a le côté nos modernes parce que il
y a des limites
culturel pourtant c'est un intellectuel
quoi que l'on puisse dire il a des
limites forte il ne comprend pas par
exemple la force puissante qu ont les
moyens de communication oui jusqu'à
certains moments mais les nouveaux aux
nouveaux enjeux de caractère économique
et internationaux et il connaît très peu
tout ce qui passe hors de l'europe c'est
encore une vision pour lui de te dire
l'europe dit retenir le monde ils
ignorent les états unis il comprend un
peu l'union soviétique et
et où j'allais je pensais hitler avait
un peu le même défaut non sans doute
j'en doute a encore plus parce que
hitler ne connaissez même pas l'europe
prient
à propos d'hitler d'ailleurs ils
s'opposaient y plaire au départ il
s'allie ensuite avec lui est ce que
c'est la france et l'angleterre qui
l'ont jeté dans ses bras comme on est ça
veut dire idéologiquement il s'était
pourtant très très proches on se dit que
c'était fatal qu'il s'entende hitler
était un peu son disciple en plus c'est
laid il est facile de le dire après coup
mais ce n'était pas une fatalité qui
étaient inscrits nécessairement dans la
pendaison dans une politique
d'agression militaire et est telle qu
elle a été produite non je crois qu'en
34 quand il rencontre hitler il le
comprend parfaitement il voit c'est
d'ailleurs la photo qui se réfèrent
nous avons là il voit que l'homme est un
fanatisme que lui n'a pas et qu'il fera
tout pour embraser ou pour conquérir
l'europe qui est le monde pour lui et de
l'autre côté il commence à sonder
surtout la france et l'angleterre et
cela dure de 34 à 36 pour voir quelles
sont les possibilités de se poser et
finalement à chaque fois ni londres ni
paris ne répondent c'est un vaste débat
sur la diplomatie de l'europe qui
essaient de faire le pacte à 4 ans 33 34
c'est vous ce lit et qui dit non c'est
le parlement français qui ne la
ratifient pas qui fait la gueule la
rencontre de stresa à trois avec la
france et l'angleterre c'est lui et
finalement il n'est pas suivi par les
anglais qui vont faire avec l'albanie le
pacte sur la parité de laval qui a été
dont le manque a été l'une des causes
qui ont déclenché la grande guerre alors
vous voyez et surtout arrive l'ethiopie
et l'impression qu'au fait des sanctions
contre l'italie fasciste et qu'en même
temps on laisse à hitler la possibilité
de détruire ce qui reste du traité de
versailles avec le réarmement de la
sarre avec la construction militaire
obligatoire et plus tard avec l'autriche
faut rappeler qu'en 1936 mussolini donc
part à la conquête de l'ethiopie dont il
veut faire une une colonie italienne et
là effectivement la france et
l'angleterre se dresse contre lui il est
condamné à la sdn et là il va
véritablement jeter dans les bras
d'hitler pas vraiment parce que si vous
prenez en 36 commence avec le premier
rapprochement mais pour arriver à une
alliance militaire il prend encore 3 ans
donnant nous n'arriverons à une alliance
militaire entre les deux pays quand 39 à
la veille de la nouvelle guerre est
encore dans cette alliance militaire de
39 il y à un article laisse cabotage qui
est celui d'ailleurs qui va permettre à
bout celui de déclarer la non
belligérance en 39 40 il entrera en
vigueur que six mois plus tard donc de
septembre 39 à juin début juin
par dix huit mois plus tard 40 et ce
sera essentiellement à cause de
l'effondrement de la france oui il entre
une fois que la partie est gagnée cm1 de
ses traits de caractère puisque déjà en
1914 vous le raconter
il avait opéré un semblable retournement
avant la déclaration de guerre il est un
socialiste persiste de balaguer écrit-il
dans son éditorial de laventie et puis
quelques mois plus tard une fois que la
guerre est déclarée donc
l'italie des n'y est pas encore là il
prône à une
comment ils appellent ça une note
neutralité active oui puis va vers le
bellicisme
entrait en très peu de temps puisqu'il
se fait virer j'ai viré de laventie il
sort il popolo d'élite alias sans doute
un journal qui est un journal belliciste
et et on le voit dès que l'italie va
entrer en guerre il s'engage et il sera
un bon soldat d'ailleurs en bon soldat
oui non mais certainement à ce moment là
il a joué bon évidemment il a reçu des
des financements mais là n'est pas la
question c'est qui la considérait son
instinct son flair son réalisme
politique lui disent qu'il ya quelque
chose du côté de l'entente qui va
l'emporter par rapport à l'alliance des
empires centraux donc il a beau faire
qui perd complètement en 40 ouais et
alors ce que vous dites il déteste
neutralité et de il veut toujours être
du côté des vainqueurs donc donc y pense
en effet que la france l'angleterre et
la russie vont emporter donc il faut
être de l'autre côté là et comme ils
pensent que hitler va emporter la
seconde guerre mondiale donc il faut
être de son côté aussi oui avec une
différence quand même que en 40 il
considère qu'il a une possibilité même
après l'intervention en guerre ils y
croient au moins jusqu'à la fin de
quarante donc nous disons six mois de
retrouver une sorte de amorce de
dialogue diplomatique européen sorte de
nouveau munich qui glacent ray la
situation d'où certaines mesures en 40
il entre en guerre avec l'idée qui est
absurde de pouvoir être le médiateur du
nouvel paix en europe comme il a eu
l'impression d'en être le médiateur au
monde des accords de munich en 38 alors
moment les accords de munich en 38 c'est
le seul qui se soit vraiment opposé à la
dissolution à ce moment-là de la
tchécoslovaquie la france et
l'angleterre aurait relié tous les
engagements en espérant qu hitler sans
l'arête la l'apologue c'est autre chose
il ya ce côté là aussi vous montrer bien
c'est qu'il est il parle plusieurs
langues amis souligné et au moment des
accords de munich il une seule qui peut
parler à tout le monde oui
at il tout compris je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas il a certainement quelque
chose qui flatte et son côté à ce moment
là disons de grands arrangeurs des
situations parce qu'ils sont beaux et se
veut également diplomate sachant
d'ailleurs que l'outil militaire de son
pays est complètement insuffisant par
rapport aux enjeux qui se font mais
comme dit qu'il déteste la neutralité
pourquoi eh bien ils détestent la
neutralité parce que ce qui lui vient de
son socialisme du début c'est quand même
l'idée qui est un socialisme dès le
début matinée de nietzschéisme et l'idée
que quand même la lutte vital est la
lutte par définition de loeb et
j'entends par là que l'espèce a toujours
besoin d'un nouvel affrontement et de
bondir en neuf ans et tout cela sans
lisent dans les années 30 dans défense
et fumeuse justement sur la virilisation
du peuple ce peuple qu'il connaît peu à
ce moment là sur la militarisation sur
l'effort mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
renoncent qu'ils soient prêts à renoncer
à toute neutralité
si les enjeux pouvait lui permettre de
sortir
vainqueur même sans la guerre par le
bluff qui est toujours été une
composante de sa carrière et de sa
personnalité vous dites il s'est
toujours présenté comme un homme du
peuple à mussolini vous dites aux
contrats que c'est un petit bourgeois
petit bourgeois qui a complexe et donc
rien de particulièrement négatif à être
un petit bourgeois mais pour lui il cela
le caractérise dans le sens d'une d'une
classe sociale qui n'obéit pas vraiment
à
ad-din des valeurs mais qui a toujours
la possibilité de sortir d'être la fois
très flexible est tout à fait difficile
à cerner donc il se promet taris
tout à fait d'une façon tout à fait à
quoi un coup incohérente et alors c'est
un socialiste révolutionnaire au départ
à 18 ans il vient socialiste très pure
et le relationnel île déserte il ne veut
pas faire son service militaire il passe
en suisse il se fait arrêter on a vu
d'ailleurs on va la revoir une photo de
lui quand il est arrêté il a je crois 20
centimes en poche il a quasiment rien
mussolini vous dites que il resté au
fond jusqu'au bout un instituteur et un
socialiste oui et un journaliste et
réalisateur c'est le premier c'est le
rédacteur en chef du daily la pause vous
si vous prenez les 50 volume 49 de ses
oeuvres complètes vous vous trouvez que
les deux tiers c'est des articles de
journaux de journal et même ses discours
il n'est pas souvent pour en première
mouture dans le popolo d'italia pouvoir
la réaction les ânes et les adaptons en
tant que discours politique il ya aucun
grand ouvrage d or aux idéologies
qu'aucun mein kampf chez lui quand je
parle de grands ouvrages je ne veux pas
être mal est inséré ça n'est pas un
idéologue
non non ça n'est pas ça veut dire c'est
un opportuniste pure qui a quand même
ses 3,4 au début au moins sont disons
son fonds de commerce qui est basée sur
justement sur le peuple et sur le refus
qui lui reste quand même et ça c'est le
côté socialiste jusqu'à la fin
odilon de l'embourgeoisement ce qui est
relativement facile parce qu'il est très
frugal de par sa nature mettre l'argent
ne l'intéresse pas vous le dire jusqu'à
la fin n'en est ni lit les choses qu'on
associe à l'argent alors vous me direz
qu un dictateur n'a pas besoin d'avoir
plus de 10 centimes dans sa poche dans
tout régime sutout siècle mais en tout
cas il a certainement cette frugalité de
fonds à côté de cela il ya évidemment la
démesure et la boursouflure du pouvoir
quand on voit cette photo on pense on
est obligé sont bien d'enlever mais on
est obligé de penser à hitler au même
âge pas la même époque prioritaire est
plus jeune hitler à munich
clochardisé oui
c'est pas la même chose vous dites même
un peu connu cela
le travail manuel mais enfin nous parle
aux docks et on en a fait le calcul de
quelques semaines mis bout à bout la
était maçon et où l'a élu à travailler
même je crois chez eux chez un boulanger
mais enfin tout cela n'est pas important
ce qui est important c'est qu'il n'a pas
connu la phase de désespoir de dèche de
solitude absolue de hitler sa solitude
est une solitude au fonds beaucoup plus
intérieure parce que par exemple nous
n'en avons pas parlé encore parlé mais
c'est un homme qui est qui et entourée
de femmes si l'on veuille 0 et ce qui
pourrait être l'opposé du caractère
hitlérien oui mais quand on quand on on
dit qu'il est resté
instituteur jusqu'au bout et journalise
jusqu'au bout dit il a été le rédacteur
en chef de l'italie quand il était au
pouvoir et il a dit l'abe au fond
infantiliser les italie revient sur
cette entente affichée en tant
qu'instituteur bien sûr y en a il est
c'est un instituteur qui aime entre vire
bull sa classe l'esmt il vraiment je ne
sais pas mais qui en tout cas ne veut
pas de lui permettre de devenir une
classe d'adultes oui
et on tant que socialiste parce que ça
c'est toujours un mystère on a vu dans
le fascisme alors selon le bord auquel
on appartient soit une extrême droite
soit une extrême gauche
le fascisme mussolinien pour vous il est
des racines socialistes profonde alors
c'est certainement un phénomène de
droite oui si nous faisons une
différence mais
n'entrons pas dans c est qu à sion
sociologique qui qui qui qui ont composé
toute une littérature mais il est
certain que c'est essentiellement un
phénomène de droits parce que nasri a
une exposante voilà justement le
nationalisme le bellicisme parce que le
show c'est la guerre mondiale mais quand
même l'emploi des gaz en ethiopie ce
n'est pas n'importe quoi donc je veux
dire il y as et puis il y à un élément
qui est certainement de droite c'est
l'idée qu'il y a des hiérarchies
naturelle entre les êtres et entre les
peuples et entre les nations donc c'est
l'élément qui
ils portent vers l'extrême droite à côté
de cela l'élément de gauche c'est son
refus de fond qui est un autre élément
de cette non modernité dont nous
parlions de certains éléments porteurs
de la société moderne donc par exemple
la relative indépendance du pouvoir
économique et financier par rapport au
pouvoir politique
et là il rejoint certainement
des visions marcisz des bolchéviques
anticapitaliste il a au départ fait
confiance au peuple le retournement au
moment où il devient belliciste on
dirait que c'est parce qu'il se rend
compte que le peuple n'ait rien son état
oui l'a jamais fait confiance au peuple
jamais oui peut-être quand il était
socialiste tout début a case 18 ans dans
le dans l'estaminet de son père au passé
le gros rouge et ont chanté
l'internationale peut être il y à ce
moment d'émotion à propos c'est aline
affectif et c'est un homme sans émotion
ne l'oublions pas aimé la fût jamais
fait confiance au peuple il se rend
compte que le peuple il ya deux ou trois
épisodes de sa vie qui le lui prouve
sans l'état n'est rien ce sera toujours
une sorte de de masse opaque dont les
pouvoirs établis peuvent s'emparer ont
fait une pause on essaiera on se
retrouve juste un trajet
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec maurizio serra
de l'académie française pour son livre
le mystère mussolini qui vient de
paraître aux éditions perrin voilà donc
un homme qui a été socialiste
socialistes révolutionnaires
anti militariste anti colonialiste qui
est également
été internationaliste qui devient
brusquement au moment de la première
guerre mondiale un nationaliste
puis qui va virer fasciste eelv a
inventé le terme et en même temps
militariste colonialiste impérialiste
cet homme est ce que c'est toujours le
même est ce que est ce qu'au fond tout
ça c'est de l'opportunisme et justement
c'est un vaste débat parce que si vous
prenez la comparaison que nous faisons
assez régulièrement dans cette émission
et qui est inévitable parce que c'est
l'histoire qui l'a fait d'un hitler qui
est le même du début à la fin vous voyez
ne se limiteraient à noaillan très
opportuniste je crois néanmoins que les
trois quatre composantes dont nous
parlions fond et surtout l'idée que la
vie est violente l'idée que la vie n'est
pas pacifique l'idée que la vie est une
opération au fond de force où il ya les
gagnants et les perdants est quelque
chose qu'il tient dès le début qui et je
dirai une composante de son caractère
qui devient une composante de son
idéologie
en même temps qu'elle devient co besoin
de son régime en mettant le fascisme
italien
aurait été plus soft que le nazisme ça
n'aurait pas été un véritable
totalitarisme il aurait été moins
répressif moins violent moins cruel -
haineux au fond et vous et vous dites
dans votre livre d'ailleurs que
mussolini n'a jamais été un homme et ne
en tant que tel comme a pu l'être y
plaire
et on voit le fascisme italien comme
ayant protégé les juifs par exemple et
c'est vrai que le fascisme de tous les
au départ en tout cas c'est l'idée qu'on
s'en fait est que de tous les mouvements
d'extrême droite européens à l'époque il
le seul qui n'a pas de contenu
antisémite au départ alors il faut
distinguer les choses nous mener votre
votre votre reflex question réflexion
pose beaucoup de de deux thèmes
venons par cette idée soft beau terme
français je ne sais pas si l'académie a
accepté dans un dictionnaire alors c'est
une idée qui à mon avis est également un
peu un cliché parce que il est certain
que sur l'échelle des totalitarismes et
et delà de la violence de la barbarie
totalitaire même ce qui se passe en
espagne au moment de la guerre civile et
du débarquement des troupes d'afrique du
côté de franco on peut donner la peau
peut avoir l'impression que le que le
fascisme soit plus doux ou me en réalité
je pense que cela n'est pas vraiment le
cas dans la mesure où le régime a
peut-être une certaine intelligence
policière était servie par de bons
policiers c'est à dire d'intervenir là
où il le faut avec un minimum de
répression pour avoir un maximum d'effet
est également la filtration dans des
cellules et tout ça il faut dire
également une chose que les anti
fasciste qui sont encore forts surtout
dans le mouvement intellectuel et dans
les partis qui n'ont pas été éliminés du
jour au lendemain comme dans la main
d'hitler yale attention après la marche
sur rome octobre 22 il faudra encore au
moins trois ans jusqu'au lois fascistes
issime dit fasciste ici de 25-26 pour
que le régime s'établissent en tant que
tel alors que font les intellectuels et
les partis politiques libéraux
socialistes même certains nationalistes
non fasciste ils ne font qu'accumuler
les erreurs enfin nous devrions entrer
dans une description très précise donc
l'homme est également servi par le fait
que ses opposants lors après l'autre
échoue évidemment il y aura le cas
matteotti kevin hommes et qui est connu
même en france et puis partent en exil
bon débarras donc de ce point de vue là
nous le trouvons dans une situation très
semblable à ce que sera pas très
semblables l'histoire n'est jamais sans
meubles surtout d'un pays à l'autre mais
l'exil anti franquiste dans les années
50 vous voyez c'est à dire le fait que
rohff et de l'opposition à franco de la
france de la suisse ou des états unis la
même chose c'est l'opposition où se lit
donc ça je pense la réponse est partie
de la question la question de
l'antisémitisme est complexe et simple à
la fois
aujourd'hui tous les chercheurs même
ceux qui sont sur des positions très
différentes en ce qui concerne le
coefficient
d'antisémitisme successifs du régime
reconnaissent qu'au début le fascisme
italia et non seulement mussolinien
parce qu'il ya fascisme qui est au delà
de mesures mais elle eu probablement le
seul mouvement d'extrême droite nous
l'avons qualifié d'extrême droite dans
notre conversation précédente qui n'a
pas de composante antisémite même les
anglais de la blake unyon des fascistes
de mosley automne elle est morte et ses
mythes qui n'est pas aussi prononcée que
d'autres ne parlons pas de ce qui se
passe en europe centrale et balkanique
alors ce qui fait que de coeur ou deux
raisons il y a une participation il y à
une acceptation d'une partie au moins de
la composante juive de la société
italienne qui est comme dans tous les
pays d'europe surévalué
son bled de son plein droit par ses
mérites intellectuels professionnels et
autres mousseux lily lui même à trois ou
quatre ministres qui sont des
technocrates
d'origine juive surtout dans les
finances et le trésor dans les années 30
40 et les assure entre 25 et à ce moment
là ce qui se passe en 38 est un crime
particulièrement abject parce que au
fond rien ne l'annoncé qu'est ce que
vous entendez par 38 parce que il ya
celle de l'allemand par nier les faits
au moment où fin 38 avec une progression
qui ce vaisseau de deux ou trois mois
d'entre eux août septembre octobre vient
introduites des lois antisémites qui
sont d'ailleurs des lois également
porteuses de restriction des avis des
autres confessions les protestants sont
également touchés la petite mais très
forte intellectuellement très développée
communauté protestante italienne est
également touché et ce sont des lois de
marginalisation sociale et progressive
qui ne sont pas si vous voulez des
doigts de nuremberg mais qui
certainement à partir de 38 m les juifs
italiens dans la situation de citoyens
de deuxième ordre et de ce point de vue
là c'est également l'autorisation par la
corruption pour une passation de domaine
de richesse de biens matériels et autres
donc c'est vraiment la page
incontestablement la plus abominable du
régime sur le plan militaire on voit
mussolini comme un très mauvais chefs de
guerre pas d'ailleurs pas très moderne
là non plus les italiens comme un peuple
qui n'a pas du tout envie de se battre à
ce moment là et au fond les campagnes
militaires italiennes comme une
succession de catastrophes c'est pas du
tout c'est pas du tout vrai en 40 41
contrairement à une image qui a été
également comporter par une certaine
résistance anti-fasciste on peut le
comprendre les motivations et par les
allemands le bas oui mais non mais le
pays s'est battu enfin et après tout
écouter deux porte-avions anglaises ont
été coulés par les italiens je lançais
pas de que d'autres pays aient fait de
même donc finalement le pays jusqu'en 41
à la fin de 41 c'est pas long mais c'est
un an et demi en afrique sur d'autres
fronts évidemment il y à la déconfiture
d'abord en france qui est
terrible et puis et puis sur le fraude
de graisse et d'albanie mais les
positions se reprennent en yougoslavie
donc la situation tient encore ce qui
évidemment change complètement la donne
c'est la guerre d'abord contre la russie
et puis contre les états unis c'est
quand même une armée mais l'équipe et
c'est une âme est mal équipée mais qui a
des positions de force et qui tient
encore raisonnablement même après télé
le débarquement sicile le débat comme en
sicile qui d'ailleurs provoquera la fin
du régime donc nous sommes au début de
juillet 43
et bien le débarquement sicile est
certainement un moment où l'armée
italienne et italo allemande s'est
effondré ans ici les allemands moins que
les italiens c'est un fait mais regardez
ce qu'est ce débarquement ce
débarquement est la répétition de ce qui
sera plus tard le débarquement en
normandie
c'est un effort de guerre
gigantesque qui est mise en place pour
une question essentielle c'est de faire
tomber le premier pays de lacq ce après
quoi le front italien dreux deviendra un
front secondaire dans la tente du vrai
débarquement que les anglo saxons les
anglo-américains honte
décidé avec staline c'est à dire celui
en normandie alors justement à la suite
de ce débarquement en sicile
en 43
le duce et d'abord renversé par le haut
conseil fasciste puis renvoyé par le roi
le roi renvoie son premier ministre
parce qu'au fond il n'a jamais été
depuis longtemps que le deuxième
personne a joué du de l'état un
mussolini il y avait un roi au dessus de
lui et au fond il reste totalement
c'est là où on se dit où ça n'est pas un
vrai totalitarisme ou en tout cas il est
très très loin d'un personnage comme
hitler c'est qu'au fond ils se laissent
destitué oui alors justement c'est une
interrogation qui bien que nous
disposions aujourd'hui d'une du 2 2
tonnes et tonnes de témoignages qui sont
souvent d'ailleurs des tbh des
témoignages qui ont été écrits après
truqués changer modifier enfin vous le
fait est que nous ne savons pas vraiment
mais que nous nous posons le doute
certainement je le pose autre mystère
mousli dit comment cet acquis quand même
est un conspirateur nez depuis qu'il a
l'âge de raison
qui a toujours comme tout bon dictateur
exercer un contrôle total sur
l'instrument de la police il n'a jamais
quitté le ministère de l'intérieur
arrivent sans presque le savoir dans une
conspiration au milieu d'une
conspiration qui se passe pendant
quelques semaines dans l'ère du pot neti
non romains où tout le monde parle
de tout et lui ne sait rien et il arrive
comme ça le soir au plus tôt la nuit ont
parfois non ça commence après midi pour
passer dans la nuit en pensant qu'il va
renverser les cartes rien que par sa
personnalité ou n'est ce pas plutôt une
façon qui correspondrait un peu à
certains côtés du personnage pour sortir
de cette situation sans pour cela que
les allemands puissent dire qu'elle a
voulu faire une une percée au premier
avec les alliés ce serait ça il se
sortiraient d'affaires pour vous une
certaine manière ça va bien se passer
comme il l'espérait puisque dans sa
chambre il est où il est arrêté il est
emprisonné oui çà et là ne peut être
prise mais revanche il est libéré par
hitler à ça ils n'avaient pas prévu
voilà
ensuite il perd le nomme à la tête oui à
la république sociale la république de
salo wii qui va durer un an et demi
après quand même oui sur les
parachutistes qui ont libéré de toute la
vie souligne alors justement libérer ou
embastillé définitivement mussolini dans
quelque chose dont il ne voulait pas on
le voit là
quand vous verrez les photographes sa
rencontre avec hitler et l'a d'ailleurs
bemba petit film il est loin d'être
heureux non je pense que certainement ce
qui à ce moment là à jouer ce n'est pas
du tout sa volonté de créer une
république sociale et par définition en
ce cas une guerre civile dans le centre
nord du pays s'est encore l'espoir de
s'en sortir
d'ailleurs ce qui est très curieux c'est
que personne ne veut de lui
les militaires allemands qui ont
pratiquement le contrôle de l'italie du
centre nord en particulier kesselring le
commandant en chef qui est un excellent
militaire souhaiterais qu'il y a un pet
un italien souhaiterait complète plus
près d'un vieux général ou maréchal
peut-être pas tout à fait lucide qui est
quand même la possibilité d'avoir un
rôle tels que l'italie devienne nulle
base de ressources pour le dernier
effort la dernière équipe et du rail et
ne pose pas de problème surtout deux
guerres partisanes et de résistance
c'est le contraire qui va se passer
les allemands du parti comme goebel se
détestent bouslimi et considère que
l'homme est finie et même certaines
fasciste irréductibles ne veulent plus
debout souligne en considérant que pour
la même raison il est belle et c'est
hitler et seulement hitler qui le remet
en selle et même à ce moment là et même
à ce moment là et mussolini reviendra à
l'italie avec l'idée de devenir
simplement eu à chef d'état symbolique
en prenant au premier ministre pour
faire le
mauvais au sale boulot et tout cela en
fait une solution pétain laval si vous
voulez les pensées un an et demi il est
quasiment plus de pouvoir mussolini la
sépareront son frein
et puis il s'enfuit quand tout s'écroule
il s'enfuit avec sa maîtresse clara
petacci alors parmi femmes justement on
imagine mussolini beaucoup plus
sensuelle keatley recouvert de femmes
vous dit pas du tout mais on est très
prude va pas porter sur la shoah et chic
très portée sur la chose je pense qu'il
va enfin pas mais mais pas dans le sens
sensuelle du terme à l'assaut comme
c'est aline affectif c'est en même temps
un nom sensuelle je ne sais pas quel
homme politique on attribue les cinq
minutes douche comprise et à chirac a
donc mais c'est un peu ce qu'on pourrait
dire de lui jusqu'à la rencontre avec la
péta clara petacci qui est là alors que
d'autres on a voulu faire eu l'image
d'une espèce de bimbo de les blogs qui
se serait jeté dans les bras de
mussolini ce qu'une fille de la grande
bourgeoisie elle a 20 ans quand ils se
rencontrent il en a 48 et ça va durer
donc présents aussi longtemps que eva
braun et et hitler mais là il découvre
vraiment la passion amoureuse d'applied
là elle découvre la passion amoureuse
est incontestable les lettres en
témoigne ce sont les seuls êtres d'un
contenu privé d'ailleurs il a été
je passe d'excellentes idées de les
publier parce que on voit un côté chez
lui qui n'existe dans aucune autre
correspondance n'y avait qu'une femme
n'est certainement avec adam c'est à
dire quand même le côté où il descend un
peu de son personnage pas toujours mais
un peu et surtout vers la fin mais c'est
une d'écrire que tardive 48 ans quand
même hein mais oui mais c'est le hasard
des circonstances enfin il omet c'est
pas certainement sa première mettrait
non pas d'accord mais c'est certainement
celle qui qui jouent un rôle
considérable surtout vers la fin et
alors à la fin ils partent ensemble ils
ils veulent passer en suisse il a une
mallette pleine de devises elle est là
ces bijoux parce qu'elle vient d'une
famille très riche elle n'a pas du tout
été entretenu par le führer comme moi
par le duce comme on l'a dit et ils sont
arrêtés par les partisans italiens
communiste et ils sont fusillés par les
communistes selon qu'ils sont arrêtés
par des partisans d'ailleurs qui ne le
sont pas mais à partir de ce moment là
par toute une opération qui étudie en
détail
à vous écouter un détail elle est disons
il ya donc sept cette arrestation il ya
ce côté qui est certainement peu
comment dirais-je
[Musique]
kian qui anoblit très peu la fin du
personnage de ce2
ce2 passé a par-dessus allemand mais
enfin après tout d'un polluant avait
bien passé le faire dessus d'un général
l'autrichien moment on est on sûr c'est
chateaubriand y voilà chateaubriand
n'ayant jamais beaucoup plus mais
napoléon y en a d'autres qui l'ont dit
également mais là n'est pas la question
la question véritable c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de spéculations autour de sa
mort bien sûr ça entretient un peu comme
les spéculations qu'il ya eu sur le
véritable cadavre ou non les cendres de
hitler dans le bouquet les spéculations
sur la mort de staline
beria et tout cela c'est inévitable cela
fait mousser l'intérêt du public
finalement nous savons les choses
essentielles nous savons qu'il est
porteur non seulement de devises ce qui
est évident dans une fuite mais
également porteur de documents ces
documents peuvent être plus ou moins
intéressants nous ne les avons pas
récupérer mais nous savons par des
témoignages croisés de quoi
essentiellement issus notamment des
lettres de churchill alors justement la
question intéressante est essentiel
c'est les lettres de chukchi je suis pas
remis et celles et ceux qui considèrent
que sauf preuve contraire que nous
n'avons pas cette correspondance qui a
certainement exister dans les années 20
né dans les années 30 où l'entente entre
les deux hommes même sur le plan
personnel était forte vous souvenez de
churchill arrive à rome 10 ans si
j'étais italien si j'avais 20 ans et si
j'ai invité italien j'aurais été
fasciste formule 1 ce qui lui a été
reprochée
mais le vrai problème c'est existe-t-il
une correspondance intérêts l'entrée en
guerre de l'italie et ça vraiment ça
tourne abonnés vis oh oh oh roman et au
mauvais roman parce que il y a deux
éléments d'ailleurs qui sont en
contradiction d'une part on veut que
churchill insiste sur mussolini pour
quillan 30 afin d'empêcher une victoire
absolue de hitler alors que vous voyez
que la piteuse opérations de la guerre
des alpes ne rencontre la france
fait en sorte que la guerre de claire
simon veut la victoire du clair soit
encore plus par comparaison encore plus
fort et d'autre part la contradiction
c'est de dire au contraire il ne faut
pas entrer en guerre ce qui aurait plus
de sens donc une neutralité italienne
possible qui permettrait en particulier
à la royal navy de ne pas patrouiller
cette partie de la méditerranée et se
déplacer vers l'atlantique et vers l'est
l'allée soumaré allemand soumaré
allemands qui ont été permis par les
anglais au co termes de l'accord navale
anglo allemand de 35 vous tu l'as voulu
george dandin et finalement ça aurait
beaucoup de centres mais en arrière
trouver on ne fait pas on n'a rien
trouvé et puis il y a également une me
semble t'il une considération que qu'on
oublie c'est que
churchill est un homme de poigne
certainement il n'est pas encore nous
sommes en jeu un jeu car en juin juillet
40 il n'est pas encore le chef de guerre
absolue que les anglais connaîtront plus
tard il est quand même entouré de
collaborateurs de services degré de
policiers surveillaient ce qu'il fait
sur l'île et des îles et en même temps
surveillé qu'est-ce qu'il fait cher
bénite qui l'enferment la lettre il met
dessus de la table et l'envoi par les
postes jusqu'au palais de venise enfin
ouais donc a priori la correspondance
rêvé par satin de sortilèges mussolini
une fois la guerre d'éclairer un peu de
champ ce qui se dit et ce qui est à mon
avis très intéressant c'est l'opération
commente le parti communiste le parti
communiste de la résistance pour
provoquer la fin de mousseline et non
pas par une cruauté autres mais
essentiellement parce que c'est le
projet politique qui permettra aux
communistes qui ont été en grande partie
minoritaire est tardif dans la
résistance pensons à la guerre avec
l'union soviétique de sortir comme en
france que le parti de la résistance et
et la mort de clara petacci une jeune
femme on se souvient qu'ils sont
fusillés tous les deux vous raconter en
détail
par surprise elle se jette devant pour
dire ce qu on a dit bon nous vous et moi
n'étions pas allés mais il ya des
témoignages mais contradictoires là où
les ménages qui sont assez
contradictoires la règle
alors moi je ne crois pas du tout à la
la mort par comment dirais-je peint par
le cev le fait la mort accidentelle
parce qu'elle s'est jeté non glas pour
trois raisons d'abord
nous savons comment était composé le
groupe de felouques savons tous de
comment était composé l'équipe qui est
allé les chercher là où il était voilà
et on sait qui maintenant on n'a pas
toujours su non mais quand même nous
donc je dois dire tous ces détails sont
assez précis vous n'allez pas me dire
que des grands personnages de comme saad
ehret résistants ne peuvent pas
contrôler une femme en empêchant
qu'elles se jette en face de quelqu'un
en train de fusil
2° l'hypothèse comme quoi si on ne
devait pas la fusiller ce serait elle
qui aurait échappé à tenir mais je
marchais qui a été fait dans le film de
mon ami câble in italy et aspirer
veulent s'emparer qui ne tient pas
debout pour cette que c'est la deuxième
fois zoo pour laquelle ne tient pas
debout c'est que l été la démonstration
du côté néfaste du dictateur qu'on
voulait même plonger si vous voulez on
revient à côté petit bourgeois chez les
italiens c'est à dire l'homme qui
abandonne même la famille qu'on aurait
coloris tripes et à ce moment là sur une
pile obtint pour fuir avec sa maîtresse
donc il ya ce côté et le troisième qui
est à mon avis l'élément fondamental si
elle est mort par accident si on voulait
pas de et alors pourquoi lui imposer
l'ignominie également de pierres sales
et lorik cedria la porte à côté de lui
c'est les pieds des boxes pieds par les
pieds et vous savez et vous savez que
heureusement je crois un prêtre est
intervenu pour lui serrer la
jupe
ces gants voilà et
quel bilan
et celui de mussolini on a longtemps dit
que
sa révolution au fond s'était réduite à
faire arriver les trains à l'heure etc
ce qui était la première fois en italie
mais l'était certainement une caricature
et bien sûr qu'est ce qu'il a qu'est-ce
qu'il a des vingt ans quand même au
pouvoir oui qu'est-ce que les aime les
italiens lui doivent les ennuis on sait
mais est-ce qu'il ya eu quelque chose
quand même de positive alors à point qui
que je souhaiterais évoqué si vous me le
permettez en terminant c'est que le
fascisme est un phénomène historique
morts et des fins heureusement non parce
qu'on me pose parfois la question en me
faisant veut voir ça ça sent abrutis
lever les bras en disant non le
phénomène est mort et des fae c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour lequel nous
pouvons l'analyser avec les termes de
l'histoire alors qu'avec les termes de
la sociologie de la psychologie de basse
nous pouvons étudier des phénomènes néo
de nos sociétés mais c'est une autre
chose
personnellement je crois que même des
gens qui ont fait leur carrière
politique disons néofasciste vous
rappeler monsieur almirante guédé
longtemps le n'y croyais plus et est
pour eux une question d'avancer leur
petit lot politique mais le phénomène
fascisme mussolinien est terminée
ce qu'il a légué c'est certainement une
frilosité
tenait le débat en séjour leur en italie
nous sommes aujourd'hui même ce sera le
premier jour de l'élection d'un nouveau
président de la république et vous voyez
des voix qui disent il faut que le
président de la république ne vit que ce
n'est pas du tout la charge honorifique
que certains considèrent en france c'est
une charge politique qui peut devenir
importante au moment de crise nous ne
voulons pas de personnel était trop
forte sinon nous allons vers une dérive
présidentialiste ni trop jeunes
d'ailleurs on il faut avoir 50 on y voit
là ça c'est un faux souvenirs
arrivé au pouvoir à l'âge où emmanuel
macron il est arrivé à monsieur macro et
je crois monsieur chirac dans son
premier mandat
jusqu'à destin n'aurait pas été quand je
le dire monsieur jusqu'à des salles
amusez vous n'aurez pas été all you need
is bref on établir et publier ça c'est à
cause de mussolini laisse assez on veut
plus un jeune président donc il ya cet
élément donc vous voyez qu'il ya cette
crispation et à mon avis c'est un
héritage très négatif parce qu'il ya une
sorte d'image l'image d'épinal si vous
voulez mais c'est comme s'il y avait une
sorte toujours justement de frilosité de
peur de difficultés par rapport à ce qui
est a passé dont certains éléments ne
passe pas encore à côté de cela il faut
avouer quand même qu'il y a
objectivement des réalisations faites
dans l'urbanisme dans toute une poussée
et ça a été une partie d'ailleurs
si vous voulez de sa crédibilité
la poussée des jeunes talents des années
20 et encore des années 30 donc de ce
point de vue l'an sur le plan des
anthropologies qu'est culturel le bilan
peut être mitigé alors que politique or
il est indéfendable
merci michael cera le mystère mussolini
ce c'est paru aux éditions perrin et
vous avez reçu le prix de la meilleure
biographie politique
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]